[Music]
what a week eh we could have talked
about all that twitch stuff the new
farcry or that halo news it was quite a
lot to pick from but last week epic
games that answered they'd be bringing
back one of my favorite franchises so
let's forget about III in the state of
the industry and all that other nonsense
this week on the point I'm gonna spend
five minutes telling you why Unreal
Tournament is one of the greatest games
ever made to adequately appreciate the
importance of UT we have to remember
what first-person games were like 399 at
this stage in the game the console FPS
was still trying to find its feet but
the PC first-person johner was thriving
the previous year had seen the release
of half-life and though single-player
was the order of the day many popular
franchises were living longer through
multiplayer doom and quake had
traditionally ruled the roost but
modding communities were creating whole
new multiplayer experiences out of
existing single-player games developers
were taking note that multiplayer was an
exciting new growth area and when the
news came out that quake 3 was going to
have no story mode in favor of being an
arena shooter players welcomed it with
open arms it's not to say that games
didn't have multiplayer back then but
they didn't really have BOTS bots are
usually made by community modders months
after a game became popular online and
the quality of their a I was pretty well
hit or miss around this time epic games
were enjoying success with the release
of their first major game a sci-fi
first-person shooter called unreal epoch
lead programmer Steve polishes working
on some BOTS that the team plan to
release has an expansion pack for unreal
known simply as the bot pack but once
mark Rayne got wind of just how good the
bots were performing he demanded the
team roll with the concept and develop
it into a full retail product but it's
reductive to say that UT was just unreal
with multiplayer BOTS Unreal Tournament
brought several major innovations that
immediately made the PC classic even
though it was released the same week as
the most anticipated multiplayer FPS at
that time Unreal Tournament was released
two days before quake 3 on November 30th
1999 so why is it the Unreal Tournament
is such a funny remembered game well
it's not just for one reason it's for
dozens Unreal Tournament had a lot going
on well first off the team at Epic took
the fantastical environments of the
single-player game and applied them to
multiplayer map design
fan maps were pretty utilitarian the
focus being on balance and flow
basically they were kind of boring but
on reals maps were beautiful unique
interesting and bloody mental you could
fight on a spaceship flying through
space or a massive skyscrapers in the
stratosphere or in a castle or this
weird meteor thing with two more castles
on it I think if you were to release
facing worlds today people would
complain that the slifer rifles were too
Opie but back then we were too busy
enjoying the fact that it it's too
bloody kasam spinning in space while all
this sick drum and bass plays you just
don't care
[Music]
and as Morpheus Tech 16 forest moon so
many classic maps there were jump pads
pressure chambers and acid pits there
was low gravity and water to fight him
some of the maps permission-based others
were deathmatch some were captured a
flag there's so many ways to play plus
the bloody things shipped with community
tools on the disk so extra levels were
just a download away use your created
maps would common magazine cover disks
and allow you to keep the game fresh for
months and years to come this is how
developers used to create brand loyalty
this is how they used to extend the
lifetime of the games now we have to pay
for extra levels and most of the time
all the good ones were already in the
game not on real tournament fantastic
Maps plus the weapons were bloody
fantastic too there's a gun that shoots
shrapnel a gun that shoots goo a gun
that shoots [__] razor blades and
they all had multiple fire modes so you
could gangsta lean with your pistol or
make goo mines hey remember that gun
that shoots [__] razor blades right
click now the razor blades explode the
rocket launcher had like 12
goddamn firing modes the bots were
clever that music was awesome there was
so many modes and mutators you could
apply them to any single map and they've
change up the level like every time you
kill someone you got fatter
he was full of fantastical environments
and weird traps and unique aspects to
every map and crucially unlike other
multiplayer shooters at that time it was
actually relatively accessible Unreal
Tournament was such a breakthrough for
the genre that the series was never
really likely to reach that type of peak
again when I go back and play it it
reminds me of just how exciting
first-person shooters were then
especially multiplayer ones how games
stretched believability and didn't care
about story just had bloody fun
I'll be honest folks this week's episode
was supposed to be about the whole
franchise but I wasted the entire
runtime of the show just spewing about
the first game there's so much to talk
about I want to talk about how you to3
looks awesome and had that really dull
American football mode heyyou T 2004
added vehicles but not just regular
vehicles Unreal Tournament as vehicles
with the friggin blades attached how
absolutely incredible ut3 was how today
it basically looks like concept art for
Gears of War that game had like
hoverboards and guns you could link
together as far as I'm concerned it was
almost a perfect game and then some
genius in the community made a mutator
to turn the Redeemer into a friggin yang
cat
but in the meantime let me just say how
incredible is that this franchise
continued to make jumping around crazy
environments and blasting the crap out
of each other just the most fun epic has
always been a studio would have done
when it's done mentality so take your
time guys there are millions of us
around the world with fond memories of
this franchise but we'll wait patiently
for the tournament to start again
[Music]
you